what's up guys is Casey from Wichita
Kansas is inhales going in her stinging
for you this is my wife in several of
her friends oh yeah cosplayers they make
costumes they go to comic-con
they run patreon it's basically make a
living doing that kind of stuff so King
under stinging cosplay guys I love your
show
Brennan you look like the oldest valet
at macaroni grill that pocketful other
people's change like something like pay
to have snaked out on my shower drain Oh
valet my crummy grilled good pretty good
cosplay they say you want to play
cosplay Bill Cosby has any people that
dress up like dope ah look here's the
thing
dr. Laura pinning cosplay man you know
that's what we called virgins when I was
in high school no say like it ain't good
man but a lot of them are freaks but if
they're older and they're in those
costumes then you're talking about
furries bro yeah you [ __ ] your eyes
you know what Furies are dude hey go
think of rocky the mascot for the
Nuggets but I walk down that movie mask
you mean sure that'd be a comment bring
him up I'd be a costume of some sort
what cat was shaking her head about the
cosplayers yeah cat knows more about it
actually cat looks like a caused by
agree cosplayers are different he
brought up patreon so I'm thinking
they're cosplayers who basically dress
and like really skimpy clothes mmm it's
all the like sexy superhero clothes from
comic books yeah like - it's nothing but
like tits and ass
Wow so it's kind of its kind of uh sign
me up a cartoon meets sex kind of yes
exactly
there's that anime I think you can
cosplay anime as well what's there
between cosplaying LARP LARP I think you
get dressed up and then you pretend to
fight people you gotta have a sword to
lure and cause you're dressed up with
your sergeant Hauk
yeah yeah oh come a counter cosplay I
thought it was Bill Cosby he will dress
him like Bill Cosby and Sheldon yeah
because I'm saying I'll dress up like
cockroach and show up and meet some
ladies you know yeah yeah no I got a
pillhead ladies showing up out there to
pose this question though just cause
congenic hi this is tough man I mean if
your girls out of shape shows up is
wonder worm won't wonder woman it bums
me out you know I'm saying a few girl
shows up as Wonder Woman
then ya know wonder world if she shows
she's been Thor I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants
and I'm soon um it's just not for me i
[ __ ] with it I'm not if you want to do
it do it
it's just nobody is saying it's not for
me man but I but I'm cool if you're into
it I get it dude right if you want to
dress up like ren and stimpy and [ __ ]
each other do it well they're not
necessarily [ __ ] this man is a wife
and they have our friends and they're
working yeah bro you think they'd dress
up as [ __ ] the Cookie Monster for the
hell of it [ __ ] no they swing those
outfits they go to these [ __ ] sheds
and do each other - that's cosplay bro I
don't think that's it I'm telling you
not just going to dress up and pretend
they're Wolverine and Professor X I
don't think that's it at all I think
sometime they're showing a little bit of
artwork and different makeup stylings I
think there's a lot more to it than you
think there is I don't think either of
us know what the [ __ ] we're talking
about what I think you showed up in a
costume of Nolan Ryan today look at you
Rangers baby hey Hassan boy the house
all right I'm king it dress up and get
weird
I like cosplay dude I think it's a risky
move sometimes but I wouldn't feels in
an outfit every day but I'd like to see
more like wrestling WWF type of cosplay
- you know I'd like to see it go you
know and I'd like to see some Bill Cosby
I'd like to see people you know do
sweaters and get out there and you know
and uh but notnot do drugs or any sex
crimes but maybe just kind of you know
you see a woman sleeping or something
just put a sheet over just a blanket
make sure she's comfortable and give her
jello yeah
create the narrative just make sure
she's okay yeah I'm with you
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]